uh pleased to say the housing secretary
robert jenner joins us once again in the
studio minister good to see you this
morning
um shall we start with christmas because
clearly it will be something that what
practically everyone is thinking about
giving we're so close to it
but also given at the potential that it
might not happen
what is the government's position this
morning as regards
the five-day window well we've set out
the legal framework as you say which is
the five-day window
the ability for three households or
bubbles to come together
if people wish to do so but we're also
saying in
guidance that this is a question that
everybody needs to to think about and as
you say
i think these conversations are
happening in households up and down the
country
uh this morning we all need to use our
own personal judgment
thinking about our own families whether
we have particularly elderly
or clinically vulnerable relatives who
might be around that christmas table
and also looking at the fact that the
rates of the virus are rising in many
parts of the country
and i think thinking about some of the
examples we could see internationally
like thanksgiving for example
where lots of people coming together did
have consequences
after the event so i would just urge
people to
use their personal judgment to think
carefully whether this is the right
thing
for their family and come to their own
judgment what what factors
should they be considering then in
coming to that decision to strike me
straight away
whether or not you'll have older people
around the table and second and one
which is pertinent to my own case
you know whether or not you have to
travel four or five hundred miles to get
to where you you want to spend christmas
well i think those are exactly the sorts
of things that people will be discussing
whether or not you've got
older relatives whether the people
around the table are likely to be
clinically extremely vulnerable um and i
i think circumstances have changed i
mean think about my own family
a few weeks ago we were i think clear
that we would meet up
because you know my mom and dad have
been longing to get the family
together i think today not just because
the cases of the virus are rising in
some parts of the country
but also because of the good news of the
vaccine has
changed some people's perspective
because many families think now
well you know what by january or
february uh the elderly members of my
family may well be vaccinated
and so why not wait and get the family
back together
you know later on in 2021 and that's the
sort of judgment i think people will be
making across the country but would
could you be explicit just for a second
if you have
people in the categories that were
shielding for example
uh during the first part of this
pandemic is it your view that we should
not be spending christmas with them
well we're not telling people how to
come to this
decision we can give guidance the chief
medical officer obviously has set out
his own views
and he's been clear that he would
exercise great caution
in bringing people together particularly
those who have certain
vulnerabilities but you can't legislate
for every eventuality you've got to
ask people in the end to use their own
personal judgment
and christmas is a fairly unique time of
year
many people have been longing to to come
together yeah and so we're offering
people obviously
the ability to do that but asking them
to use their own good judgment
but but again the situation does appear
pretty confusingly take the yougov
snap poll suggesting i think it's 50 57
of people actually think the christmas
window should be dropped add into the
mix
the british medical journal the health
service journal
legions of scientists all suggesting
that this christmas bubble will lead
directly to
a third wave and deaths well the legal
frameworks i say is there people have
the ability to make use if they want to
but no one's being asked to do that
we all have to come to our own judgments
as i say i suspect that many people's
views have actually
changed or are changing as they're
deciding whether or not this is the
right thing actually
for their own family in my own personal
circumstances that's the case
i think many other families across the
country are coming to the same judgement
do you want to know it's not right
the government can legislate for every
eventuality life is far too complicated
for that indeed
there are some people but you can
provide people who are actually very
vulnerable
who might choose that actually they'd be
looking forward to christmas they don't
know how many more christmases
they've got ahead of them they want to
come together with their family no one
is denying that there is a divergence of
opinion and all of this i spent half an
hour going through our
sky news inbox this morning and you know
aside from the usual complaints might be
being rav cnes but nowhere
definitely two camps in all of this no
one is denying that
but it is confusing for the public on
the one hand you have opened up the
christmas window so that people can
spend time with their loved ones
then we have you the health secretary
and others saying you really need to
think carefully
about seeing your loved ones over the
period you have people taking their
children out of schools
so that they can self-isolate so that
they can see their loved ones
and then you've got the education
secretary forcing the schools to open
and telling people to put their kids in
it you have to concede it's a confusing
picture i don't think that's the case
there is a legal framework that's clear
that's across the whole of the united
kingdom but it's not
compulsory to do that it's obviously a
matter of your own personal judgment
and my instinct is that christmas is one
of those unique occasions where
people do want to come to their own
judgment about what's right for them and
their family as i say
many people will conclude i think that
actually it's better to
have a smaller group just your own
household maybe your own household plus
one other person who's part of your
bubble on this occasion
we've seen many other holidays and
celebrations conducted in that way of
the course of the year
including other religious festivals from
passover to diwali
uh for other faiths so it's certainly
something that can be done it has been
done
but it's a matter for you to come to
your own judgment we know that there is
a
conference call with the the devolved
nations uh this morning but as things
stand
the prime minister from what you're
saying is not minded
to change anything about the christmas
window now our position is
is clear i hope that the legal framework
will continue
but because the rate of infection is
rising in many parts of the country
because we can see the international
examples like thanksgiving
it is incumbent on each and every family
across the country
this morning and in the days ahead to
have that conversation around the
breakfast table
is this right for our family to think
about those factors that we've discussed
the particular
vulnerabilities of members of your own
household
and those who would be coming in for
christmas and come to a judgment
what is the modeling telling you about
how many people may die as a result of
the five-day window
well this is a virus that thrives on
social interaction so bringing more
people together even for this relatively
short period of time
uh it is not cost-free it will have
consequences in terms of
increasing the rate of direction please
please be explicit people will die but
that
these are the sorts of judgments that
people need to bring up
how much do they want to uh bring
members of their broader family together
at christmas or whether they think on
this occasion
let's just keep it small and we can meet
up in the spring you know easter can be
the new christmas for some people well i
mean many people
many people will hear that and see a
strong suggestion from the housing
secretary that actually guys
maybe you don't want to do christmas do
you understand there are conflicting
messages this is fine for you to say
no i think because the decision the
difference between the difference
between us with respect is that you want
the government to tell everybody what
they should be doing at christmas
and my view is that the government can
set a legal framework
and then it's for people to use their
good judgment you can't legislate for
every eventuality
particularly something as sensitive as
christmas where people will come
to different judgments based on the
vulnerabilities of their own family
and how important this is to them
because there are many people as i say
who have been longing to get together
at the end of a very long and difficult
year and i think we have to respect the
fact that people will come to different
conclusions can you
then give us an update as to how the
vaccination program is going we have
figures for scotland
we have figures for northern ireland we
don't have figures for england again and
and once again we hear reports from
doctors
from gp surgeries that they are adding
doing numbers
ultimately almost essentially on the
back of a fact packet
they're using scrap bits of paper to try
to come to totals why do we not yet have
a total for england
well we will do soon but we're going to
do it in a in a
um a sensible way when we've got
the data together it's properly verified
then we'll publish it we certainly don't
want to be publishing
data that we're not a hundred percent
confident of
we have rolled out tens of thousands of
vaccines a very large quantity of course
as you know
we are the most advanced coach in the
world at rolling out a medically
efficacious vaccine so we should be very
pleased about that hundreds of gp
surgeries are now taking part in the
exercise within england
alone as soon as we have uh properly
verified data we will publish that and
then we'll begin the process as we did
with other things earlier in the year
of announcing them on a regular basis
but but why are scotland and northern
ireland in a position to furnish us with
that data and england is not i mean it
does
so we all take different we all take
different different
the most important thing as far as we're
concerned is that we get
the data right we make sure that it's as
accurate as possible we certainly don't
want to have
any suggestions that uh it's not correct
or it's going to be subsequent
corrections
and so if members of the public who are
interested in this are just able to bear
with us for a short period
we'll soon have regular data being
reported the the problem as i was going
to go on to say
is that when it comes to data around
covert this government does not have a
particularly good track record
there were significant problems when it
came to reporting mortality numbers
there were significant problems
when it came to collating the number of
tests that had been carried out you know
ed conway and roland manthorp here
discovered that you know people were
doing the sums on bits of scrap
paper and once again we find ourselves
in a position where the government can't
get control of the data
and as you keep telling us the data is
central
to the administration of our public
health strategy well i think
what you're suggesting is that it
actually would be wise
to wait a few days or a couple of weeks
to make sure that the data's in the
right position before we start
publishing it
what we do know is that the uk has moved
incredibly fast
on this topic we have the first vaccines
to be
medically approved and they're being
rolled out across the country before any
other major
country in the world is in the same
position so we've moved at pace
but let's make sure we get the data in
the right position before we start
publishing it
how do we sort the problems though in
collating that data gps surgeries are
reporting
that the software through which they are
to register the information
isn't working that they're being booted
out of it the the spinning wheel of
death
is appearing on their screen more often
than not well obviously the health
secretary and the top health are working
very closely with the gp surgeons who
are participating
uh it has been thus far a relatively
small number around 100
gp surgeries so we're working closely
with those but those numbers are rising
very rapidly you know they're doubling
every couple of days and so the
important thing now is that we work with
those gps
the fantastic people who are rolling out
the vaccine and we make sure the data's
right before we start putting in the
public domain i mean you yourself have
mentioned that there are issues what are
those issues
well there's always going to be a degree
of teething issues when you
launch something as ambitious as a
national rollout of the vaccine but
actually from what i've seen i'm not the
health secretary i'm not
of course as close we should always
always have my colleagues but from what
i've seen thus far
actually this exercise has been a huge
success we've managed to get the vaccine
over the line it's being put into the
arms of elderly and vulnerable people
across the country
probably as we speak and bring hope to
people across the country
another of your colleagues dominic
cummings once again in the headlines
today uh reported that he has had
a 40 pay rise what on earth is going on
in government
that someone hired on a hundred grand
can get not an extra 40
000 pounds in their pay packet well
dominican has obviously
left the government now but i understand
that he was given a pay rise
to bring his salary broadly in line with
those of his predecessors other people
who'd been
and the prime minister chief of staff to
former prime ministers
uh this is a significant amount of money
obviously
but it's in line with say the chief
executive of a
medium-sized local council
and the amount of money that we spend on
political advisers
within government both this government
and its predecessors is very small by
international standards a very small
portion
of the amount of money we spend on the
broader civil service
and i think they do do a good job for us
you know they're 40 percent
important function we are delivering on
our promises
at general elections and it ensures the
political
impartiality of the civil service so i
think special advisors play an important
role in our political process but i
completely understand
that ensuring pay restraint amongst
politicians
and the the public sector is going to be
very important in a time when other
people
in the private sector are finding their
wages squeezed yeah tv
presenters as well um let's maybe
conclude on a topic that will be coming
up through the day
heathrow third runway um obviously we're
expecting a decision from the court so
we can't comment on that but
the government is very very keen to see
you know the the third runway build
start
well the the government has taken the
view under this administration
that it's a matter for the private
sector this is a runway that's going to
be
built and paid for by heathrow and its
partners
and so it was right that if they wanted
to pursue this project it's a massive
and important national project then they
pursued it
they've also taken this action through
the court we'll have to see what happens
later today
and on your own brief it does appear
that conservative backbenchers have won
the day that the shires are not going to
be seeing
new homes built and said it's once again
going to be the cities
uh that will get the well the benefits
and the negative impact
of a housing program well that's not
quite right all parts of the country are
going to be building more homes
we're already building more homes than
any government has done since 1987. i
want to see that significantly increase
in the years ahead and so that will be
happening uh whether you are
uh surrey or whether you are manchester
or stoke-on-trent
but i do think it is important that we
try to direct
more of those new homes to our big urban
centres
those are the places where there is
generally brownfield land so we're not
building on
the countryside it's where the
infrastructure is there that's the most
environmentally sustainable way to build
new homes
and covid has also changed a lot of the
dynamics it's magnified patterns that
have existed for some time
and given us actually a generational
opportunity
to repurpose offices and retail for
housing and that's one the government
wants to grasp
robert jenner good to have you in the
studio this morning and despite my
questions i do hope you can safely spend
some time with your parents this year
thank you